I was touched from behind
meant that was under my dress
packed in that so at my law me
somehow I still tried to
fight back my arm
I have thrown the stairs
even fallen down almost for that reason
because just so many people were there
that you can no longer control yourself
had himself
we have only many ads at the moment
be present
we know that data from a group
have been committed by boys
Men between the ages of 18 and 40 30 die
visually from the
North African from that now to
to make a topic about generalizations
and connect with that
refugee issue is nothing more than
an instrumentalization
now it's about the facts
enlighten and from it also the
necessary conclusions